um you saw
the coach coach brandt oh that was good
news we saw we so my brother hunted down
connected steve
not only did we hunt him down we went to
the new wrestling facility oh you're
wrestling oh yeah
he gives yeah
he unlocked it he unlocked it for us
because the new coach was in vegas with
it at a tournament yeah yeah so he had
key like we went this is a two million
dollar facility is your name still up
there by the way can i yeah go ahead go
ahead go ahead i know you guys have
talked about how you used to wrestle
poway and stuff yeah
steve is a celebrity there
his name is everywhere his picture
is everywhere up on the walls behind
glass cases on plaques what
it's amazing is dude yeah
is that real
that is real heal steve when you walk i
feel bad for him though cause the window
would wait where were we talking about
where
the way he talked about you it's oh wait
don't don't point just slow down wait
wait wait the way he talked about you
degrading disrespectful demoralizing
yeah he talked about you like you're
still in rehab
all right bobby am i lying i got
offended on your behalf right it was the
way he talked about it it was insane all
right so let's go
dude oh he said he coulda woulda shoulda
he goes
he goes bobby
he said bobby graduated from the school
of wood i couldn't show up
oh jesus
he said
[Laughter]
all right [ __ ]
enough said dude it's crazy right so
coulda woulda shoulda raised and you
know what's the best part what we caught
on camera so you can re-watch it
no we have it on camera yeah yeah we
vlogged everything did you explain to
him though just dude he this is what he
said he's like oh what i heard he does
comedy or he's he said it like it was
such a disrespect such a dismission he
was like oh yeah i heard he didn't he
was i guess
i guess he's a comedian or something now
oh oh we talked about it for like a half
hour in his car like dude isn't that
like he was in his own microcosm like
yeah it made me realize like he that's
his world what was your relationship
with him when you were explain the story
ah all right
so in my junior year in high school okay
i went to rehab and went to the mcdonald
center okay
when i got what's so [ __ ] funny dude
keep going no no keep going when i got
out of the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] bro i love it this is good
all right
so my junior year right so my senior
year i'm sober now okay i had got
through the summer i'd gone to a bunch
of meetings and and me and my sponsor at
the time
decided because i had to do so many
credits in school to graduate
that he said um my sponsor was just like
you you have to cut weight down to 105
you weigh 125 now damn i don't think
that's a healthy thing i think we should
more focus on the school work maybe take
the year off because you don't really
like wrestling anyway or whatever
so
i went to coach brown center i remember
vividly
like a coach
he's like 105 right we're getting ready
i go i i'm not gonna wrestle this year
and he go he looks at me like this
and that's the last
exchange i've ever had with him oh
you're dead to him
[Laughter]
i have your back oh you have my back
yeah there's more to life than wrestling
i know not in his eyes
and that's why he's a winner man
produces champions
you know who graduated from the school
would have cut a [ __ ] out with honors
bobby lee
yeah yeah didn't tom delonge graduate
from there oh yeah oh yeah yeah but he
didn't graduate from that school he
wasn't on the wrestling team yeah the
wrestling team was uh it's in a
prestigious
sporting event at our school it's so
nice the new features the new facility
the new facility is like a college
like division one yeah like a real
facility
like number one oh they're like
nationally ranked yeah yeah it's crazy
they have a slammers program now for
kids
they hooked us up you guys yeah we went
to yeah we got these there because steve
was there he let us have whatever we
wanted he's like oh yeah take whatever
you want if we would have gone with you
yeah i don't i don't know but yeah you
know
bobby you should go
wait hold up
yeah but this is the thing you forgot to
mention
that he was mad because he was sl slated
to wrestle varsity
so that's important you know i was of
course i was going to do a varsity 105
pounder yeah a senior
i know he would would you rather me
[ __ ] do meth and drop the weight and
go [ __ ] wrestle my senior year or did
you would you rather me be sober which
which i did fat and sober fat and sober
dude can i ask you this did that
technically the coach can't say that he
wants one or the other but we know which
one he wanted
he's very very hollywood of him yeah
yeah can i give bobby yeah give it oh i
get one yeah okay my bad
oh can i open it up yeah
no i wanted to say this no no no no what
go ahead call me okay i'm not going to
say nothing so this is not a birthday
thing or this
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no just
open it up so open it up i will open it
in a second okay
but is this going to hurt me no no
it's not going to rub it this is all
about respect dude
it's out of respect it's not going to be
a shirt that says shoulda could have put
away the university
oh jeremiah's smiling you're going to
get that merch the new merch at tiger
belly
oh wow why'd you get him an xxl
oh baby come here give it to me bob you
want to say a message to the coach yeah
bob give branch to her a message right
now please give him a message dude you
gotta dude tell me your credits man we
need to reconciliate tell them your
movie credits man you gotta let the
world know man go ahead man go ahead man
that brand said or no all right man all
right i'm okay i'm kind of hurt
all right i'm kind of hurt i think i can
get through it
why are you so why are you acting like
that right it's crazy it's crazy right
but can i i'll be honest with you yeah
it does burn
and i feel it
it burns in my heart damn it's like a
low burn on the bottom half of my heart
and it's probably going to linger there
for a couple of weeks it breaks oh i did
the same thing
like the reason why i didn't do well in
school is because
if i had a test
i wouldn't do it until that morning
study
which sometimes works for some people
like i've always been a very efficient
procrastinator
were you did you get good grades in
school steve
uh
when you were a freshman i was in high
school and we had the same math class oh
wow so you were a senior he was a
freshman you're in a class with your
little brother yeah i don't remember
yeah we had the same one yeah one half
of the semester so you're probably still
algebra so my brother was in
regular
freshman year and i'm in [ __ ] class
yeah like that's you never you just
never excelled in school i'm done even
no you're not done
but even in uh junior college you didn't
it was yeah your heart wasn't in it you
didn't i would go to a room he's not
good with structure yeah he doesn't like
it we'll go to a room there's a pat
lamar campus it's a community in san
marcos they had these like little rooms
that you could just walk in and there's
a piano oh you would play the piano just
play the piano for eight hours you're
just a creative person they say now that
the the rate of graduation has actually
gone up because high school is so much
less boring
like there's they you know they curtail
it to more of what works for a learner
like him or a learner like you not
everybody learns the same way right yeah
so they're trying to change the
curriculum to make it kind of
more
um
specific to
one student like you're in science to go
you want to build build a snow castle or
whatever they do yeah you know and then
i build one they don't have subjects
anymore so they learn it in like a more
um holistic type of way so i hear that
high school is so much more fun now than
when we were in high school which sucks
i [ __ ] yeah it's like high school was
like
high school was like then you'd be in
biology class and you don't understand a
word they're saying
right and then you i learned how to
sleep with my eyes open
no i did i could fall asleep with my
eyes open i can't
and then one time my junior year
i was such a bad kid they had me you
know like they had regular desks but
then they had a desk for me with the
walls
right so i had i was in the last row but
i had the walls so because they knew i
wasn't going to listen anyway so we just
sit there and one time
and then mr what would you i forgot his
last name but he looked he went over the
wall he saw you yeah and i was like this
and he didn't say anything do you watch
like he saw he caught me
oh god i mean i guess i've done that too
we had a substitute teacher mr holt yeah
and we were there's a two parts of the
chemistry room there's where the chairs
are at and then there's a lab behind it
and i guess i blew someone well because
he put on a movie he was like the
laziest substitute teacher so he would
just kind of like you blew somebody in
class yeah back in the lab in the middle
of the
oh class but i really liked him
i really liked him like he was my crush
of all crushes never do that with me
you wouldn't blow me in a [ __ ] class
you take him to a science lab right now
yeah blow him i've blown you in the
weirdest places ever what are you
talking about yeah you have like where
are you wait give me give me three
places three places
i want to know
three because he here's another thing i
used to do though
is when i was on because when i was
using
i would ditch class math yeah on math i
would ditch class and i would go to the
[ __ ] library of the school
and i would read
scientific like
books about like
weird sexual [ __ ]
and i would jerk off in the [ __ ]
library
power yeah who were your friends in high
school like his people did you guys have
different i was a john i was on the
wrestling team and i was a christian i
was a part of the students he was he was
i was i was he was not even you're a
christian he was like one of those like
i was like die hard like bible thumper
no yeah take
the bible
and then paste the [ __ ] pages on his
wall
yeah the verses it was like you know
hardcore hardcore did do you still pray
i don't believe in religion anymore when
did that happen for you
no maybe yeah maybe in college when i
took acid or something it's something
shifted i'm like this is just
yeah this is all [ __ ] because
there's other there's another dimension
in my dorm room and there's dead people
this does not making sense so let's go
to an unhelpful advice uh before that a
fan named jay actually sent in they
found all the old yearbooks at poway
high school yeah you were hot dude so
that's that's 80 that's 87 yeah and then
here's 88 i think your sophomore year
you're on a tennis team they did an
article on you yeah wow which was pretty
cool well that wasn't the article that
was the yearbook oh yeah like when
people go um i'm not athletic or i mean
or
but what exactly are you doing there it
says bobby backhand it says bobby lee
shows his latest dance moves while on
the tennis court
yeah but i was doing this a following
through with a backhand yeah you're
pretty i didn't do a double i didn't do
a double hand back hand i could do a
single which is like the fancy one yeah
it's the fancy one you were really a
good looking kid and then this is uh
junior year there we go dude next to the
cathedral really good luck yeah and then
senior year
oh sweetie how cute yeah yeah i look
like a you started getting a little
fatter
that's the turn of the the bus turn
banter
okay is that senior year the van you've
got to drive by now it's going a little
slower past them
but that that senior year though right
yeah it's from a different school so
i'll tell you what oh mount carmel okay
that's mount carmel right
so
mount carmel high school and poway high
school right we they they use the same
photography um studio oh remember i told
you so what they did was
they saw mine and mount carmel was 60
asian yeah right and in at poway high it
was like three percent so they just
assumed that my photo was in the wrong
section so they send it to
carmel it's cool and that's why i never
went to mount carmel but i'm in the
mount carmelo
look up there senior your photos that's
you're joking no that's a true story
that's a true story because look how
many asians are on here that's why they
go there's no way that this guy went to
poway that's [ __ ] crazy so racist
that is so racist it's still racist yeah
look we have one two three four five six
on one now go back to now go back to my
junior year uh photo from poway high
right here yeah yeah
oh
see bobby lee let's see
i can't believe that
oh this if they just send the shoes no
but the other freshman year that uh this
one no yeah what each guy go that one
right one girl
there's one it just doesn't seem as
asian right right yeah right go up and
down maybe yeah yeah it's all white
people oh white yeah yeah so that's why
they made that assumption and i remember
now granted i was sober so i was in a.a
right yeah so i got sober at the end of
my junior year my senior year now i'm
sober right and then the yearbooks come
out and i i'm frantically looking at the
senior and now and then i make a call to
the administration and go um because i
remember taking the photo right let's
not let you know if you put a tie on him
i put a tie i did the whole thing right
i got i'm sober i'm going to wear a
sweater yeah you know i mean
no that's not yeah go back to the senior
one yeah yeah go back to the senior yeah
so keep working i wear like a vest this
and that right yeah and i'm not in it
and i remember calling my sponsor when
they go oh we're so sorry but your photo
was sent to the other high school right
and i remember i can't believe this is
my response i i i think i'm going to
relapse yeah because i did all the
things right you know what i mean he's
like come on body it's just your senior
year right now i don't really care about
like it did hurt me back then no that's
that's hurtful yeah it didn't hurt me
about that yeah the way that makes me
want to cry because it's like very
racist it's so racial
and also there was like only there was
no apology from their end right they
were just telling me the fact well
you are asian and they're you know they
were like very like
factual about it right and you know
because mount carmel's primary
yeah you know you look like alan laguna
so
so yeah so it was like
i mean look at it they i mean they just
assumed yeah is that insane yeah and and
poway high school still today it doesn't
look like an american yearbook this is
how she shows up that's how racist they
are yeah they still won't put me in the
hot the power high school walk of fame
hall of fame hall of fame really yeah
they have a hall of fame right no one in
there has anything remotely in my
credits right right right one guy played
like the violin in some symphony you
know i mean 20 years ago and it got in
to be fair tom delong from blink 182
isn't on there either yeah because tom
dolan went to my school they view my
high school views
my kind of fame not real
it has to be associated with you know
guy like michael wang like this is what
does he do yeah like this guy he is a
part of the hall of fame yeah
he's a doctor he's a he's a doctor you
know that's what they view right yeah
yeah but he is chief of ophthalmology
yeah i did the tonight show at 29. let's
go after five years of doing stand-up
that's a big [ __ ] deal a big deal
that's a doctor yeah [ __ ] you yeah you
were on me i didn't eight years uh an
asian guy korean dude on a american
sketch show yes for eight years [ __ ] you
that's something too it's right it's
huge it's huge
like what what what the indian girl
what's her name abi ami adoshi what does
she do
yeah
pediatric hospitalist yeah they're all
in the medical field right you should
get a doctorate i should get my doctor
and if they don't [ __ ] put me in a
zen i'll i'll never go you know i think
this is just a part of the larger
theme that comedians don't get respected
this may not be yeah may not be a korean
thing like the the other the yearbook
thing was definitely an asian thing yeah
yeah yeah definitely but this could be
just like you know we don't get an oscar
we don't get
any respect there's no yeah there's no
award shows we get slapped
yeah but now i have some now okay jensen
roof
high school
but what else is that's it yeah you
won't return his phone calls okay that's
pretty good he's okay okay well there
you go there you go matt you aida uh
matt you ate is also high school but how
was he
um
what is that who is he
is he the other fanny funniest guy voted
for yeah yeah you were angry about that
funniest in high school yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wait what
what is this
there's another asian guy who was voted
most like funniest guy okay i went to
powerhouse
and i graduated in 1990 right if you
look at first of all in the 1990
yearbook book
of hawaii high school
i'm not in the senior class photos
they took my photo and they sent it to
mount carmel
because they used the same
photo
agency or place and when they looked at
my photo even though i was in the powy
stack
they go there's no way he goes to power
high because he's asian
really yeah and they send it because
because mount carmel was 60 50 filipino
so they said so my senior year i never
went to mount carmel but my senior year
pictures in mount carmel yearbook
and secondly it's so funny
yeah it's terrible i almost i asked if i
could sue but
i was yeah it's you know it's a part of
your memory and then they did that and
and then think about
when you find that information out
you're like wait a second so i'm not in
our yearbook
and they're like no you're in the other
the rival schools yearbook
they're rivals yeah yeah
but i am in a lot of photos so that kind
of made up for it they had like one page
with me and my friend craig dancing at a
dance yeah i mean and an improv me doing
improv i want the theater one so i was
fine but um matt ueda is this japanese
dude i went to high school how come his
photo didn't end up in mount carmel
stack because he's more i had like a
really like
orange kind of like um tint in my hair
and i had kind of a mullet he looked and
i dark yeah it was dark you were
filipino yeah yeah yeah i look like a oh
i see if you look at my instagram way
early on there's a photo that i have
super tan where it's like i look like a
um filipino magician
i have a vest on i don't know why i look
at that
but anyway um matt you ate a um
he's a funny dude
famous now or dude no no he still lives
in poway but um
and he i wasn't even nominated that's
the thing
when they i found out there was like
nomination there was like five guys
and i kind of asked her okay am i not
like no you're not like i would ask
friends you know but don't you think i
should have been knowledgeable but the
people like what was it like theater was
here no i was in theater
oh you weren't he was just more like he
was more popular yeah i was not liked i
get that i wasn't in any of those lists
yeah yeah i'm like i'm kind of there's
you know it's you know it's so funny
it's
you know you you don't choose where you
grow up
your parents do
so you're just exposed to these people i
like them and i have fond memories
i know but
you know when he won
i still think about it at night
yeah i hate those things too because it
is such a popularity contest most likely
to be this yeah
i'm not done
hey if they don't accept you what
picture did your you had a your picture
end up in the wrong high schools
yearbook maybe you'll end up in their
hall of fame
oh yeah yeah so okay all right so i
don't know if you guys know this but my
senior year at poway high school
i
you know we got our yearbook at the end
of the year there was a mix-up and they
didn't have my photo in the senior year
you know
and i went to the administration and i
go um because i was really sensitive
about it
it was devastating
and i go um
my photos what are they gonna recall
they're not gonna they don't give a [ __ ]
and they go oh well uh let's we'll do
some investigating what is george doing
there
and so thank you
and so that there was a school
called mount carmel
that was like all filipinos right and
there was like 40 filipinos that went to
that school super asian because it was
in a town called penisquitus and there's
a lot of filipinos that live in
peninsulas
i ended up in their yearbook
but it was i i did some research how
does that happen i'll tell you it was
the same photography company
and i bet your money they looked at the
pile of powerhouse oh we had a mix up
and they just put my [ __ ] headshot we
have space here yeah yeah and they just
put it so i'm in the penis hold on then
we could
theoretically
nominate you for both schools and see
which one takes you
yeah theoretically yes but you power
high school first because
you know i took classes you know pawi
high school was the school where after i
graduated
they had a they were a kid was allowed
to go to school saying that
um being gay is
a sin
right and you're you know and he wore
this shirt around campus
and the administration was okay with it
you know what i mean this is the same so
i believe
that they nominate people based on a
christian values value system but it's a
public [ __ ] school
right it's not a christian school right
and i could argue in court that i'm more
famous than at least 40 of the people
that are on [ __ ] on that list dude if
you took this to court that would be
amazing i might
that's how my brother got me all riled
up
he got me seeing red man
and i'm going to say this too and i i
went to crystalia
i went to whitney cummings i went to
every comic i could and i i made my case
you should call your agent i'm going to
call caa yeah i made my case and i said
is this something that i should make us
think about you know what they said all
you said yes you know how we went and
had um
a big conference with your um agents and
your reps at caa yeah you should have
brought it up then as a like top
priority and it hung up was your did you
lose your virginity to a prostitute
no
i um
he was 10th in line that was 10th in
line
and i'm just going to throw that out
baby the way you said that
the way you just [ __ ] said that you
spit in my [ __ ] face i did that was i
wanted to spit in your face
she said it very sweetly
[Music]
yeah she was almost proud of you i was
the last one in line yeah oh it was it
was ten out of ten okay yeah yeah well
it was one girl she was very progressive
whoever that girl was to think that i
want ten in me now dude i wanna watch
that video yeah well this was they were
all in high school so maybe i'm gonna
say this
one of the guys in line
when i was in my first rehab
so one of the guys in line in that line
i went to rehab and then my friend
from high school visited me at the rehab
and he goes that guy has aids
i remember being in the rehab
i'm gonna die from aids
i didn't have it
you were 10th new life
how did this go down
i know you i don't want i i don't want
this girl because i'm sure she's great
and i'm sure she's a clergy woman
everyone you have sex with is a clergy
person okay clergy woman now yeah but um
she was just like this heavier set girl
who was kind of lonely and i was on the
wrestling team
and she just kind of had sex with a
bunch of guys how did this go down
though was that a party okay i was with
the wrestling team at a party and she
was like just come on over yeah and we
were all in a room good for her and i
just kind of remember waiting in line
i got my leg was that disneyland
thursday morning
no fast pass yeah no fast pack also it's
like shouldn't a smaller guy go first
because i would but it went from heavier
to small yeah yeah which is not fair
next time reverse it by the time you got
there was she over it was she still no i
think she really because i remember that
a couple hours before that the lights
went off in in the party and she grabbed
my head and she made out with me oh
yeah she was into me
in a weird way i cannot believe yeah ten
guys yeah
so um i don't know what happened to her
and i hope she's doing great you know
sorry about that she's a closer she's a
woman she's with the lord apologize she
she put up something she put up some
numbers
it took me 10 years to get 10.
wow she probably wanted to go to college
having you know wanting to say that
number how many times you've been at 10.
you're right you're going to be one just
one night yeah you're right you're right
there was a girl in high school that was
an english girl she was a foreign
exchange student
and she was really pretty
and she was the only one in high school
that wanted to go out with me
but in my head i never she sounded weird
her voice
because i just never heard an english
accent before or whatever that that's
what threw me off oh wow that [ __ ]
weird yeah that's weird there were so
many moments in my life where i wish i
head back
that and also that guy in nashville that
grabbed me at that restaurant so i went
also talking about stevie weebe
something came up and um
at first i didn't think it was a big
deal because i've been thinking about it
over you know over the last couple of
years and it doesn't really bother me
until my brother
so we're you know i did his show and my
brother and i were hanging out
and uh no we were at parks barbecue and
my brother goes
yeah man they're disrespecting you dude
you know how steve does it right
who the [ __ ] disrespecting me
high school did your high school was
disrespecting you dude
i go you mean the school i went to paw
way high
he goes yeah dude you're not on the
poway high school hall of fame
and i go i don't care about that
like why would i give a [ __ ]
he goes it's disrespectful dude it's
about ethics see what's right or wrong
and stuff like that
and then i started sweating
i go you're [ __ ] right he convinced
you yeah it's about the ethical quality
of the situation
and he goes look at it so he will go to
power high school's
alumni page
and i i honestly i honestly have tried
to be like
sensible about it right to go okay
maybe the people
on this list
right are way more famous than me and i
get it
because if it had like matthew
mcconaughey right yeah um
what's the magician's name david blaine
david blaine yeah right right
if they had anything like that yeah bill
clinton
he's not a magician yeah magician
builder no no no no bill clinton that's
a good one you know what stop shaming
this one local middle hollywood actor
gabby knows magician that was good so
bill clinton
so you go you know i would if those
names were on it i'd be like yeah [ __ ]
yeah i'm a [ __ ] comedian who gives a
[ __ ] right
but we googled every [ __ ] name did
you really oh yeah we googled every name
on it right
and i couldn't in my head
figure out
why they got on to this honorable list
and me and tom delong
from blink182 went to my school he's not
on it he's not i'm not on it and what i
realize is that
the only people they nominate are people
with
christian values
what are we doing babe oh no i'm having
some gastrointestinal upset and i think
i might have just um mouth burped oh
it's oh it's so good
yeah you heard it yeah yeah yeah i'm so
sorry it's fine babe all right but i'm
on a rant right now
all right woman i'm sorry
i'm sorry so anyway we and then he then
i started getting rage eyes
when my brother was like see who's this
guy like click on somebody uh yeah we
have uh justin woodruff okay what does
he do from 1996. what do you do
obviously he's one of the most
well-known orthopedic surgeon
specialists in arizona
[Laughter]
wait and you are who bobby yeah that's
impressive he fixed this human body
yeah but i'm telling you right now is he
the only dude that does that but you fix
human hearts
and minds
and feet dreamweaver i'm a dreamweaver
all right i create cascades of magic
mentally with my words
you know it yeah people hop on clouds
and they live in the netherworld
through my through our
joy
do you understand what i'm saying george
i could have said it differently it
didn't make any sense what i said but
you get what i'm saying it hits me in
the heart exactly all right
so i'm asking
tiger belly listeners
to do a simple thing
i think we should get sick no you can go
to the paway high school
alumni um
um hall of fame website
pawaihyaalumni.org dot org nominate a
candidate you can nominate a candidate
and i want everyone to fill out this
form
right
i want hundreds of thousands of
nominations for both tom and bobby first
me though first bobby yeah first do me
and if you have time
okay no don't put your [ __ ] hand out
yeah can i give you a saving grace can i
give you a saving grace
okay before we left
he said a lot of stuff about
if you can see and the scissor bros up
yeah
but one of the things that i did yeah
before we left because i asked him i
said hey do you have any influence
on the high school hall of fame
and he goes i do know some people on
this he knows the board
so this is what i said
this is what i said no just hear about
this fellow brother i thought of this
wait
let me just get this straight okay
you're going to be on the shoulder
do you want to make me cry right now no
no really yeah because if you tell me
that i'm going to be on the board and
i'm going i'm going to be in the hall of
fame i will start to cry right now the
scissor bros is going to make that
happen oh you guys are going to broker
that deal he already emailed him already
emailed him i
have a beautiful email with your list of
credits and why you should be considered
yeah we're waiting on a response yeah
this is real this is real though he says
he has influence on the board you are so
funny yeah
and you're gonna be in the hall of fame
of poway
where okay you know here's where i'm not
here please help me people
where where are you it's all positive
news
is not even on it
well forget tom it's but as we know with
everything else it's all who you know in
that in that field and he has he's a
pillar of the community there and i
asked him i was like
is there any way like
okay yes that being said this is the
closest we've gotten i'm just saying
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen i
have my response to coach brown center
okay with all the information
okay okay okay think about it think
about please think about it i already
just did no really thinking he tells me
to think about it all the time
all right now go
okay hold on call him cochi no
voice or reason yeah like hi coaching
i'm not gonna call him okay
all right it's me bob
let me just hurry
dear kochie
it's me bob
hi
pretty good
um i want to say from the bottom of my
heart i'm sorry that
in my senior year
that i chose not to
participate in the wrestling program
um i felt like i was focusing on
my sobriety and who i am as a person and
trying to figure out what this whole
thing life is but in retrospect i do
apologize i also want to thank you for
your influence
right because
you're the first man i've
i've seen harry
harry knuckles
he had hairy
knuckles no honestly i remember as a kid
you remember yeah yeah i remember him
like you know because i'd be like on the
bottom like drink couch yeah and you'll
get no you gotta grab the wrist like
this right so you put his hand on over
the other guy's wrist and i would see
his hairy knuckles
and i would go i remember thinking to
myself i go i've never seen that before
that's cool right so
you're my first hairy knuckle experience
right you're also somebody i was scared
of but i looked up to and i think that
you're a true champion of all time okay
and i also want to say that if you can
help me
facilitate this hall of fame situation
right that my gratitude will go
so deep
towards you and your family and to your
bloodline
right we'll have a framed picture of you
and i would fight for your bloodline wow
right
and um
is that good
keep going i love it fantastic i love it
so love dearly love right
cochi
i mean heart heart right
and putting quotes
bobs
little bobs
thank you
thank you so much for doing that yeah
now i want to say something to you yeah
what
thank you
thank you so much
jeremiah jeremiah
because what you've done
okay
is you've created a little monster here
what my brother